[Musique]
la dernière fois qu'on vous a parlé de
ces amoureux syrien il était en train de
faire leur résidence en médecine
familiale à l'hôpital d'al martel vous
plaît ça n'a plus de bon j'ai tellement
de marché j apprends marchés généraux
fini c'est fini
j'avais plus peu grâce à la confiture de
framboises c'est parce qu'il ya des
choses que vous avez été guéri des
choses qui paie quoi vous habitudes
culinaires sirop d'érable moyet surtout
ma fille times quand même le beurre de
pinottes trois ans plus tard ils sont
devenus médecins une famille est citoyen
canadien à voir c'est vrai que tu es
citoyenneté syrienne mais j'avais rien
de mes droits
actuellement je fais citoyens canadienne
j'ai tous mes droits de citoyenne
canadienne c'est les gens qui vivent pas
ça à yahr peuvent pas sentir ce
sentiment vraiment c'est de savoir cette
liberté de de voter de choisir la
personne qui va me présenter c'est très
important
c'était sur des fierté de faire partie
de cette virée nation éthérée un pays
démocratique qui a bien cherché bien
mérité sa démocratie et on est vraiment
fier de faire partie de ce pays
garde fin et manar ont fui les bons
miles ou leur clinique avait été
lourdement endommagée je n'ai pas pu
retourner guerre en syrie a fait près de
5 millions de réfugiés
nous devons d'accepter immédiatement 25
mille réfugiés syriens
cet engagement a été dépassé le canada a
finalement accueilli quarante mille
réfugiés et des milliers d'autres sont
venus en tant qu immigrants c'est le cas
de roy cas wall les faits seuls dans les
portes 10 est toujours bienvenue à votre
nouveau pays balkaniques add your own
c'est toujours ici j'écoutais j'écoute
ça toujours ici c'est le mari de roy qui
avait choisi le québec mais c'est elle
qui est arrivé en premier seule avec son
fils de 9 ans ni l'une ni l'autre ne
parlait français elle a songé à changer
de province mais les classes de
francisation l'ont convaincu de rester
ça fait pour moi en motivation pour
vraiment apprendre les langues et j'ai
dit non à prendre français gsm en
français ma part c'est pas bien j'ai
fait beaucoup des héros à les
conjugaisons mais j'étais pas n'importe
pas n'est pas capable d'en rire
aujourd'hui mais l'adaptation a été
abrupte
c'est pas facile j'étais prof de chimie
pour 15 ans et après je suis commencé
dans les héros pour apprendre les
langues pour essayer autre autre diplôme
essayer autre chose après s'être perdu
dans les dédales des démarches
d'intégration n'a syrienne décide de
créer un groupe d'entre aide
j'ai mon idée ok je vais faire en groupe
on facebook s'appelle welcome to canada
et je vais partager toute mon expérience
et si avec 65 mais l'abonné roi est
devenu une référence auprès des
immigrants de pays arabes
elle traduit dans leur langue des
informations utiles sur une foule de
sujets
de l'immigration à la recherche de
logement jusqu'à l'inscription sur les
listes électorales
je vais voter pour la première fois de
ma vie parce que toujours avant dans mon
pays et les voter c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vraiment voter parce qu'on n'a pas
les choix pour choisir les gab hors de
moi et c'est la première fois que je
vois vraiment démocratiquement dans mes
souvenirs je pense de voter une fois
peut-être en séries mais c'est vraiment
par part parce que sinon on peut être
questionné pourquoi j'ai pas été votée
ces nouveaux canadiens suivent de très
près la campagne électorale il ya pas
mal d'idées mais je pense encore il
manque beaucoup de choses par exemple en
santé on parle pas beaucoup de santé la
médecin un break ottawa de nos provinces
les moyens d'offrir gratuitement des
traitements de psychothérapie et de
physiothérapie gars devant lui à une
préoccupation typiquement québécoise
leurs hôtes
ça paraît bizarre mais on parlait hier
la dre la sapad les routes et sont
parfois ils sont tellement vo ça fait
contraste avec le reste du pays
je pense je vais voter pour les lib real
d ouais ils sont en fait beaucoup pour
les réfugiés pour un physicien rien
c'est pas encore clair pour nous le plus
important pour eux l'ont c'est savoir
que notre avis compte
on va voter pour quelqu'un mais notre
avis il va compter même s'il n'a pas
gagné mais c'est ce plaisir là là qu'on
va exercer pour la première fois
[Musique]